I regret to say that I am professor
Schneider for today and we'll talk about
nationalism and ethnic conflict and give
you some sort of training and discussion
points for the readings for this week
which were selected by Professor
Schneider and you will have an
opportunity to discuss them in
considerably more detail in your
sections so what are we doing this today
what are we doing with today's session
in a sense we are returning to some of
the questions with which we started this
semester questions of political identity
and political behavior that really
surfaced when we talked first about
States and citizens nearly a month ago
having examined how states interact with
each other and looked at different
perspectives on American power in the
world focus once again on the
relationship between the local and the
global and particularly look at what is
ordinarily pretty local politics the
forces of globalization obviously
impinge for those of you who have
already done the reading you can see the
relationship between individual and
community identity and the forces that
are global in scale that contribute to
shaping those identities but it's also
true that we are looking at individuals
and communities when we talk about
ethnic groups nationalisms Nations and
so forth like much of what we have done
in conceptual foundations to this point
and much of what the rest of the
semester will be devoted to questions of
of ethnicity and nationalism are
bedeviled by definitional debates and
this is not only important because some
of us like the abstract debates about
definitions but because depending
on how you define some of the terms that
we'll be throwing around this week
depending on how you define a nation how
you define nationalism how you think
about what animates nationalist
activities a set of policy
recommendations are likely to flow from
that so I'm going to be talking about
some of the issues that are involved in
the definitions that we are that people
use for ethnic groups for nation for
nationalism and so forth and again at
this point it may seem on the abstract
side but in fact as you will see I think
today and certainly by the time you get
to your discussion there is a very
important relationship in this instance
as in many others between how you define
the terms you're using and the
conclusions you draw about what ought to
be done in the relevant policy arenas
there is a vast literature on
nationalism very little of which will
you be exposed to directly over the
course of this week but let me recommend
that there are some very good websites
that can provide you with bibliographies
there's one called the nationalism
project nationalism project.org which
has a very good bibliography if you want
to really root around in this literature
and ever there are in this very large
literature the lots and lots of people
have examined the issues around
nationalism there are three or four
principal debates first are the
definitional debates how do we define
nation how we do we define national
and what's the relationship between
belonging to a nation and being a
nationalist secondly where donations
come from how do we attribute history to
what we have concluded our nation's once
we finish defining it and how do the
nations and nationalisms develop are
they things that have been the same
since the beginning of time or do they
change over time
not only are there different particular
nationalisms but as there's something
characteristic about nationalism today
that was absent 300 years ago what is
their nationalism 300 years ago and
finally although not finally because as
you could imagine these are debates that
go on forever how do we manage relations
between and among nations are between an
among ethnic groups so those are the
some of the kinds of issues that
characterize this literature and about
which we're going to be talking this
week all right so what is nationalism
and where did it come from in some
respects there are two features to the
way we talk about in the way we think
about nations and nationalism on the one
hand is a aspect of the notion that is
attached to individuals it's a an
attitude or an identity so it's an
attitude of affiliation and attitude of
identifying with other people that
identify with the same community so
individuals are implicated in
discussions of nationalism there have to
be members of the name
there have to be people who recognize
themselves as members of a nation some
of the members you can attribute
membership to if you want to and you can
say well I know that all of this group X
or whatever group you want to describe
them as and there may be half a dozen
people if you will in that group that
don't say I am an X but by and large
nationalism assumes that the individuals
involved will be able to say I am an X I
recognize my individual relationship
with this larger community so that's one
side of this coin and that's an
important side because you couldn't have
a nation full of people who didn't
recognize who didn't acknowledge that
this was part of their identity and
secondly it is also in important ways an
activity or nationalism is an activity
designed to achieve and sustain
something so not only are you an are you
and X are you a member of this community
but you aspire to certain things for
that community typically what you aspire
to is some version of self-determination
for the community not for you as an
individual within it but for the
community as a whole
so not only am I and X but I think all
X's should have certain kinds of rights
should have rights for communal autonomy
should be able to make decisions for the
community of X's so I am both as an
individual this is my identity but I
also attach a certain ideology to that
identity so nationalism in a sense has
two phases it has a face as an identity
and attributing certain features and
characteristics to that identity and it
has a face that's really an ideologies
that there are certain political
consequences
there are different ways to describe
this but in a sense it asserts
nationalism asserts the supremacy of the
nation's claims the being and X over
other claims to individual allegiance in
other words of the mill many many things
I could be I could be as I we've
discussed this before I could be a
member of my into my nuclear family I
could be a member of my neighborhood I
could be a member of all so I could be a
member of my University my place of
employment all sorts of things but the
most important thing to me is that I'm
in X fill in that black whatever nation
you want to use as your example and as I
say so it it makes claims for my
individual allegiance and it argues for
self-determination for all of the people
who make that claim who has that
allegiance now art what alternatives are
there at this in this modern world it's
hard to imagine the world without
nationalism it's hard to imagine a world
where people don't identify themselves
as members of a community that is in
some respects associated with the idea
of a nation well obviously some of the
other things that I just described could
be alternatives I could prefer to
identify myself with my family I could
prefer to identify myself with my region
of origin which is not a nation and
doesn't aspire to national status I
could identify myself as associated with
my professional association or other
kinds of identities but typically one of
the things that characterizes the last
150 years is how powerful nationalism
has been in providing identities and
providing vehicles for political action
and in some respects the only thing that
has been as powerful a collective
identity over the court for political
action over the last hundred and fifty
years or so it's class remember workers
of the world unite you have nothing to
lose but your chains so for the last
hundred fifty years or so class identity
identity has been very powerful in
driving political action and people
could describe themselves as members of
classes but he tells you something about
how quickly history fades when it begins
to fade that that seems virtually
completely implausible at this point and
most identities for politics are really
about ethnic identity and national
identity so I could be a member of a
political party and that could be more
important than anything else to me or I
could be a member of my family and that
could be more important than anything
else to me but typically in this day and
age many of these identities end up
congealing around an ethnic or national
identity the intellectual debates around
nationalism however over the last 150
years are very often best understood and
I commend this perspective to you in
contrast to debates about class identity
in other words there were say in Eastern
Europe in the latter half of the 19th
century in the first half of the 20th
century very powerful important and
interesting arguments about what the
most effective and most important
identity ought to babies as people came
in to from Eastern Europe into debates
with Western Europe and thought about
development and thought about the
purposes of development and thought
about the empowerment of communities and
so forth these were this was the context
in which these kinds of large-scale
identities whether they were class or
whether they were national were seized
and animated during that century or so
now naturalism proved to be particularly
powerful say many of the national the
social scientists who study nationalism
and nation's nationalism proved to be
particularly powerful because of its
association with States one of the
things about many of the political
movements associated with class analysis
with international socialism and so
forth was that they were deliberately
opposed to the divisions represented by
states nationalism of course is not
States it may be a particular
nationalist movement may be opposed to a
particular state but it's not a
principle opposed to the system of
states and in fact is almost predicated
on the system of states because if you
assume that nations aspire to at least
autonomy and at most sovereignty then
they're really talking about a
relationship with the state system and
what they want is not to destroy the
state system so much as what as to
become a member of the state system to
have the nation expressed in a sovereign
state as Ernest Gellner whom you read
and who is one of the major figures in
many of the debates around nations and
nationalism put it and I quote
nationalism emergence only in the milieu
in which the existence of the state is
already very much taken for granted okay
now this is an interesting point to
which I will return momentarily but know
that he is already saying that there is
nothing timeless or ancient about
nations and nationalism he's saying that
basically starting with the Peace of
Westphalia and the development of the
state system you begin to see
nationalism and most nationalists
advocates most nationalist nationalist
political figures will argue
that the particular nationalism that
they're advocating it is ancient okay
comes from the distant mists of time
this community but gathers already
tipping us to what's going to turn out
to be a very complicated question about
the nature of the nationalisms that we
confront today but let's pause for a
moment and think to ourselves why should
it be related to the state what what is
it about the state that would elicit
these kinds of identities if we assume
as gildner does and I will make this
case in more detail in a minute that in
fact nationalisms appear simultaneously
and very often after the appearance of
the Mazda state well remember when we
talked about the relationship between
states and citizens and the extent to
which the identity of the citizen
associated with the state is very thin
rule that a citizen is interchangeable
equal before the law
faceless all the same stripped of any
uniqueness or defining characteristic
for all the same as citizens in these
new modern states well obviously you're
perhaps not obviously but one can
certainly argue that for many people
particularly people who did not enjoy
the full rights of citizenship this is
not enough it is not enough simply to be
an abstract member of an abstract
community you want we want one wants an
identity that has some substance to it
that actually celebrates the variety of
people in the world and the uniqueness
of each of us and says yes speaking that
language heading that history enjoying
those traditions those things are
special and important and they should be
washed out of our
political identity on the contrary they
themselves give us a community that is
deeply important to us as an identity
and should be represented in this world
of states so the states themselves begin
to both elicit and reflect if you will a
substantive content a character of
community that they are supposed to be
the sovereign expression of so there's
an an intimate relationship between what
develops as a political identity and
political ideology and the appearance of
this state system that we talked about
some time ago so the unique
characteristics of us the things that
make us interesting or not that we are
you know a voter because we're all
voters that doesn't tell us a but the
kinds of things that ethnic and national
identity prize that we speak certain
languages that we come from certain
regions that we have certain kinds of
histories that we enjoy certain cultural
traditions and patterns of behavior and
things that we enjoy with other people
who enjoy them too and that's the
beginning of that kind of community
these languages and cultures are
important to us they are part of our
identity and we identify with other
people who have those languages and
cultures particularly for people who
felt themselves if you will be hung the
most modern countries that is to say in
the 19th century in Eastern Europe and
then later those in the rest of the
world who felt themselves oppressed by
Imperial control nationalism was a way
to a certain value was a way to say this
nation of which I am the people who
speak this language the people who come
from this area the people who have those
traditions is as important and meriting
as significant stain
in the world as the first states as
France or Britain or these kinds of
sovereign entities to which we aspire
now we being as I say in Eastern Europe
in the 19th century and in much of the
post-colonial world in the 20th century
so we see the beginning of nationalism
we see the beginning of political
movements built around these kinds of
communities and we can see the beginning
to some extent of why there would be if
you will a space for that kind of
community in this growing state system
but that still doesn't tell us entirely
about what a nation is and what kinds of
things contributed to the development of
the nation's once you have this state
system that begins as I say to sort of
if not illicit it leave a space for
concentrating on these kinds of
identities among the most popular
definitions of a nation is that of
Benedict Anderson and so I'm going to
quote him at length to give you a sense
of the factors or the features of Nash
of an emanation that he has drawn out
this is on the website that I gave you
before as well of course in his book
imagined communities reflections on the
origin and spread of nationalism
he says a nation is an imagined
political community and imagined as both
inherently limited and sovereign so yes
nations are communities that aspire to
sovereignty there are many communities
that don't and whatever else they may be
from his perspective they are not
nations now he goes on to say it is
imagined because the members of even the
smallest nation will never know most of
their fellow members never meet them or
even hear of them yet in the minds of
each lives the image
their communion this is an identity
that's important to me and I know that
there are other people out there for
whom it is also important even if I
never encountered other communities are
to be distinguished not by their falsity
or genuineness in other words if I know
that it doesn't really matter whether
other people could say oh but that
didn't exist fifty years ago but by the
style in which they are imagined so he
discusses non national communities
he says Japanese villagers for example
have always known that they're connected
to people they have never seen but these
ties were once imagined particular istic
way as in definitely stretchable nets of
kinship and client ship until quite
recently the japanese language had no
word meaning the abstraction society so
one of the characteristics of a nation
is that it is abstract it is not simply
all the people i might be related to it
transcends that it's something that goes
beyond simply the personal connections i
may have and they may have it's more
than iterated six degrees of separation
it is actually an abstract idea that i
have imagined myself as a member of this
community as he puts it to go on and
this is another way of thinking about
the same issue we may think of the
French aristocracy of the NCN regime as
a class today we impose the idea of
class nests on that aristocracy looking
retrospectively but surely it was
imagined this way he says only very late
if you ask who is the Comte de X nor the
normal answer would not have been a
member of the aristocracy but the Lord
of X the uncle of Barone do I or a
client of Duke de Zeeuw in other words
until you had these abstractions the
idea of the
and the idea of the nation people
imagine themselves only in terms of the
extension of their personal connections
now we have an abstract as he said
imagined community now the nation is
imagined as limited because even the
largest of them says he encompassing
perhaps a billion living human beings
has finite if elastic boundaries beyond
which lie other nations so just as the
existence of the state is predicated on
the existence of a state system the
existence of a nation is predicated on
the existence of other nations I can
distinguish myself as a member of X
because I'm not a member of Mladic but
there are people who are members of Y
there are other communities that I am in
contrast to so there have to be multiple
nations for the idea of this imagined
community of nationhood to make sense
no nation imagines itself coterminous
with mankind now one could argue and
perhaps you want to play with this in
section as you discuss this that perhaps
cosmopolitan this as we are beginning to
understand it that cosmopolitan identity
is actually coterminous with mankind and
is actually a 21st century version of
this kind of identity but certainly when
we talk about nations and nationalism
no nation imagines itself coterminous
with all of humanity and finally it is
imagined as sovereign because and again
on quoting Benedict Anderson the concept
was born in an age in which the
Enlightenment and Revolution were
destroying the legitimacy of the
divinely ordained hierarchical dynastic
realm nations dream of being free the
gauge and emblem of this freedom is the
sovereign state
so a nation does aspire to sovereignty
now some never achievement but that
aspiration is characteristic of a nation
and finally he's
as it is imagined as a community because
regardless of the actual inequality and
exploitation that may prevail in each
the nation is always conceived as a deep
horizontal comradeship ultimately it is
this fraternity that makes it possible
over the past two centuries for so many
millions of people not so much to kill
as willing to die for such limited
imaginings so those are the elements of
what goes into the way we understand
what a nation is are there different
kinds of Nations within that
comprehensive definition well for
gildner there are Eastern western and
eastern kinds of nation nationalism and
other people talk about civic and ethnic
nationalisms ethnic nationalism is more
characteristic of what I was describing
before with an emphasis on culture of
language tradition common
characteristics of the members of the
community language origin tradition
culture sometimes at its extreme race
membership in these ethnic nations is
understood as involuntary that is to say
if you were born with those
characteristics you are a member of the
nation and the state reflects the
essential character of the nation when
there is such a state and classic
examples include Germany and Turkey both
of which are ethnic nations reflected in
States or a civic nationalism any group
of people aspiring to or loyal to a
common state membership is here in some
sense voluntary and the classic case of
civic nationalism is the United States
and you should reflect on what it is
then if there is any content to American
national
so what it is and professor Sistani
bitch talked a little bit about what
might characterize an American
nationalism but in that notion of a
civic nationalist and the state reflects
consensus around common political values
legal norms and moral commitments far
more than it does around a common
language or cultural tradition now
rarely is the distinction quite as
clear-cut as I just suggested most civic
nationalisms have some ethnic component
to it and most ethnic nationalisms have
some some civic characteristics but the
distinction is exists in the literature
and it may be useful as you think about
what kinds of policies to manage ethnic
and national conflict you would advocate
for example there is a dispute right now
or a debate right now about Israel as a
Jewish state
that's an ethnic naturalism or Israel as
a democratic state granting all of its
residents equal political rights that
would be a civic nationalism so even
today even in moe in particular
instances the definition of how the
content of the nationalism is understood
will shape policy in quite dramatic
terms in that instance now most
discussions of nationalism are about the
first kind about the aspirations of an
ethnic group that does not have or has
only recently attained sovereignty this
is in part because most states have
nations of some sort but many nations
the Iroquois that curves the burghers
the Yoruba did not have States and so
one of the characteristics of much of
this discussion is not about the civic
nationalism associated with sovereign
states but about ethnic nationalism is
particularly sub-national
on national non-state nationalism good
aspire to sovereignty okay so where did
these things come from another debate in
the literature where does these where do
these identities come from and where do
we understand it now obviously as you
can tell from my reliance on Gelder and
Benedict Anderson the much of the social
science literature sees these identities
as quite modern and very much a
reflection of relatively new
institutional forms like States but
typically nationalists themselves favor
and foster myths of common origin in the
distant past national identity for many
of the nationalists in the world today
is timeless and what we call primordial
that is to say never shaped by anything
so whatever your national affiliation is
X has always existed and people have
always belonged to X from the very
beginning of time and X may have been
beleaguered by opposition by Y's and Z's
but there has always been an X and in
fact it probably has a very valiant
history of fighting off the depredation
of Y's and Z's nationalisms always
almost always do so they have long and
distinguished heroic histories and they
are invariant in their existence they
have always been there in that sense
States should reflect pre-existing
nations nations were always here say the
Nationalists they are primordial and
they and the relationship between these
nations the X's and the Y's and disease
often reflect what are routinely
described
as ancient hatreds so when you see
language like that about the fact that
the X's and Y's had never gotten along
and that one of the things that we're
going to have to deal with if we think
about managing conflict is managing the
fact that these these people have never
gotten along the people who are making
that kind of argument or implicitly
endorsing a primordial list
interpretation of the nature of nations
and nationalism obviously this is not
Anderson or Gilmer's position and indeed
they argue and this is again something
you may want to consider that a
committed nationalist somebody who is an
advocate for his or her national
identity sovereignty and so forth it's
fun cannot be a social scientist
and a social scientist cannot be a
committed nationalist because the
committed nationalist needs to privilege
that nation and that nation's history
over other nations and over historical
interpretation that might suggest that
this nation did not always exist and was
not always Billy heard and was not
always deserving of sovereignty whether
he had it or not there is a variant
between the completely constructed
version of nationalist minute and
primordial which is a sort of perennial
lyst position arguing the nations have
been around for a very long time
although they take different shapes at
different points in history this can be
more easily reconciled than the
primordial its position with social
science although as you saw Benedict
Anderson thinks that those kinds of
early senses of common membership in a
community were not the abstract
nationalisms of the modern world and in
fact he and many people who study
nationalism believe that nations are
built often through the very hard work
of nationalists s-- and you are or my
affiliation with nation X is partly a
reflection of the fact that I have been
advertised to I have been recruited to I
have been persuaded that this is the
most important identity I could have and
that it takes NAT nationalists a lot of
very hard work to see flowering that
kind of affiliation with the nation
reviving languages inventing histories
nations are constructed so the
constructivist in international
relations theory we find this
interpretation of nationalism obviously
completely congenial now clearly you
construct with things that are available
materials that are available to you you
don't construct a national identity
around a completely invented language
Esperanto did not produce nationalism
but you can take languages that are
liturgical languages languages that are
minority languages languages that seem
to be disappearing and construct
political identities around
and that has happened repeatedly look at
the history of Eastern Europe look at
the history of the Middle East language
has been very important in the flowering
of national identity in those regions
sometimes nations reflect States and are
constructed around the existence of
States this is obviously true in the
case of civic nationalism but it can
also be true in what becomes over the
course of time and ethnic identity and
one of the most wonderful works
illustrating the creation of an ethnic
identity is a book called peasants into
Frenchman by Eugen Weber and it's a
wonderful description of how people in
France over the course of time come to
think of themselves as French as opposed
to their local identities their regional
identities their dialectical identities
Eric Hobbs balanced position also a
wonderful student of nationalism among
many other things is typical he says
like most serious students and we're all
serious students here I do not regard
the nation as a primary or as an
unchanging social entity it belongs
exclusively to a particular and
historically recent period it's a social
entity only insofar as it relates to a
certain kind of modern territorial state
and it is pointless to discuss nation
and nationality except insofar as both
relate to it alright so the social
scientists among us are interested in
nations because we're interested in
trying to figure out how they come to be
constructed and how once constructed
they come to take on a very powerful
life in politics within states between
states among other national groups and
it's a politically important distinction
nationalists are above all political
actors and argue the reality
the ancientness of their ethnic groups
are claims have certain ones standing so
when you think about the ways that
people analyze nationalism and then the
ways that they advocate nationalism
those are two very different projects
and for this week we are analysts and
then those of people want to be
advocates should feel free to do so but
for this week we're Alice and one of the
things that's interesting about the
intersection of analysts and advocates
is that you can as an analyst see you
can disaggregate the vehicles with which
nations are put together so as I
suggested you have you know the revival
of languages or and this is important in
part because of the abstract character
of nations everybody who speaks a
similar language is going to be part of
the nation whether we know each other or
not and in fact Anderson argues that it
is a in part because of the what suppose
preach capitalism the increasing
availability of newspapers in vernacular
languages that permitted people to
imagine themselves as part of a
community of other people who read those
newspapers in those vernacular languages
but there are other ways in which people
construct these sorts of identities and
one of them is of course archeology and
looking at the ancientness of the claims
so one of my favorite examples of this
is looking at the archaeology of the
Italians in Libya as they during the
interwar period when Italian nationalism
was at its highest when they were trying
to claim that their imperial project in
Libya was the revival of the Roman
Empire so doing archaeology and finding
Roman sites in Libya where they were the
imperial powers was one of the ways
they justified their claims to the
territory because what Italy was and so
they were and they called Libya the
fourth Shore what Italy was was the
modern incarnation of the Roman Empire
and their control of the North African
territories that they had in Libya was
justified because the Romans had been
there and you could see that because of
the archaeological sites so that's part
of the way that nations are constructed
and glued together and the way that the
moral claims that nations make are
justified languages history all sorts of
things are brought to bear on
particularly when they are competing
claims there will be competing claims
over interpretations of history over the
primacy of particular languages so forth
that's right you can no doubt think of
examples yourself okay now if you even
if you argue that nations or perhaps
particular if you argue that nations are
constructions at least in their
political eyes you will want to know how
that nationalism is catalyzed what makes
us active why are we not just sitting
around being happy axes well part of it
is that there is an intrinsic
competition if you will because as I
said as with States there isn't a single
state there is a state system and
similarly with nations there isn't a
single nation there is a system of
nations but what catalyzes the awareness
of that and then the awareness of other
nations is as or at least Anderson
argues is things like print capitalism
is things like being able to read and
realizing that only some people are
reading what you're reading
people are reading other things and
reading it in other languages so
language becomes one of the important
features of modern nationalism in part
because of the importance of the
technology of the printing press
technologies of communications in other
words were part of a part of the
features around which people develop
these common identities and in that
sense lynches discussion of al-qaida's
particularly interesting because in a
sense what he argues in that piece about
al-qaeda as a constructivist project is
that it is a function of new
communications technologies that is not
only permitting people to interact with
each other in novel ways but is
potentially creating opportunities for
new kinds of identities identities that
are not linked only to the technology of
the printing press or the character of
vernacular languages so he argues that
the al-qaeda's principal goal is the
construction of a new transnational and
trans State identity based in Islam to
define the interests that follow from
this identity and to create transcendent
norms that would establish a logic of
appropriateness governing Muslim life so
in other words he's analogizing to the
construction of nations through emphasis
on the printing press and on common
vernacular languages that Benedict
Anderson did he's analogizing and saying
there's something about these new
technologies that are going to privilege
different kinds of identities and that
these identities may or may not operate
exactly the way classic national natural
isms and nations have operated so you
can think about whether you think that
in a sense al-qaeda is
very little to do with identity and
ideology a great deal to do with
identity in the ideology but in the same
way as classical mesh national nations
and nationalism or a modern very much of
that that's really a reflection of new
kinds of technologies for communication
certainly that's in part what Lynch is
arguing there is a public and private
outreach there are entrepreneurs who are
trying to create this identity and
trying to get people to adhere to it
from the global media to innovative uses
of the Internet to in addition intensely
personal recruitment now Lynch is
obviously a constructivist but I want
you to also to note the extent to which
he points out the temptation of a
primordial list interpretation of what
al-qaida is doing as he says there is
nothing obvious or natural about the
Islamist identity proclaimed by al-qaida
to take this as the application of a
deep essentialist identity is to grant
Bin Ladin victory in the single most
important stage of constructing reality
the rhetoric about a global Islamic
identity and aims to driving a
self-fulfilling prophecy constructing a
collective identity rather than simply
reflecting it and in that sense this is
very much like the nationalist
entrepreneurs they want to create
something that people will then as a
self-fulfilling prophecy find their own
identity and find a political movement
in but as you will as anyone who reads
the newspaper well know there is a very
strong tendency temptation to see the
Islamist movements as born in and
reflecting primordial Islam rather than
see it as being constructed out of
available materials but also using
brand-new technologies and that would be
the way people understood the
development of many of the National isms
in the world today okay why do people
subscribe to nationalist ideologies even
if people are exposed to ideas that
permit them to imagine themselves in
communities that transcend their
personal experience why act on those
ideas well again there are a seven there
are a number of different approaches to
this sort of question one of them I've
been suggesting that there are sets of
elite entrepreneurs who create the
circumstances in which people adhere to
these sorts of identities and ideologies
and they're competing with other kinds
of entrepreneurs for example as I
suggested earlier there was a very
powerful competition to nationalism in
socialism and communism as a organizing
vehicle for identity and for political
action and there were entrepreneurs who
were competing for the loyalties of all
sorts of people throughout Europe and
the rest of the world during the late
19th and early 20th century for
precisely those kinds of identities and
those kinds of political movements so
one way of thinking about this is that
you're looking at the incentives of
individuals and a nationalist would say
that there is doesn't need to be any
incentive that actually we are all proto
nationalists ourselves anyway and we
just act on behalf of our nation out of
love for our fellow members of the
nation so there's a natural it's natural
to be a nationalist or it's irrational
to be a nationalist that you're being
manipulated by the elites this is a form
of false consciousness or it's rational
to be a nationalist
and there are a set of theories
associated with rational choice that
suggests that nationalism is a way of
engendering
trust among community members that makes
their cooperation easier and it's
therefore a lubricant in relations among
rational individuals so it could be and
the analysis will you will see all three
of those kinds of approaches that
there's nothing to explain
that of course there's something to
explain but the people are being
manipulated and they are falsely
conscious or there's something to
explain that this is really rational
action and therefore one could expect
that rational actors would affiliate
with these kinds of communities and
identities because it makes it easier
certainly for in-group interactions and
to have strong in group interactions
typically you have hostile out group
interactions and that's one of the ways
to think about the relationship between
national nationalities and ethnic groups
when they're in conflict this
rationalist approach does raise another
interesting question which we do not
have time to talk about today but you
may have time to talk about section
which is when does it make sense to
switch identities if you're thinking
about this as a matter of rational
choice then in a sense any calculating
individual would decide that it may be
smarter to be an X than a Y or a why
then an X in at any given moment
this obviously suggests that natural
identity is not something you're
involuntarily forced into or stuck with
because of where you born what you were
born in is but did you have options you
can change if there are appropriate
incentives for a rational individual and
there are a number of interesting
studies that examine when people seem to
switch from one kind of identity to
another in circumstances in for example
Eastern Europe and the former Soviet
and a political scientist named David
Layton has done a lot of this sort of
work but on more local ground in any
event when do the Irish living in the
United States decide that they are
Americans of Irish heritage that's a
choice and it's a set of choices that
presumably can be understood in terms of
the rational calculus of the individuals
in question all right those are the
sorts of things that the students of
natural nations and nationalisms debate
all the time let's assume for the moment
then we've hacked our way through the
underbrush of definitional debates if we
have all concluded that we know a nation
when we see one and we know nationalism
when we see it in action and there is
some sort of consensus on those
questions which obviously there is not
in the literature including the
literature that you've been reading for
this week how how does nationalism
intersect with other kinds of political
processes it doesn't appear and develop
in a vacuum there are pre-existing
States there are other nations there are
kinds of political institutions there
are political processes of various kinds
so where is nationalism in all of this
this is this has a couple of normative
features and some empirical features the
normative in some respects are the more
interesting but not something where we
will be detained by long but it's worth
keeping in mind that nationalism is sort
of if you will morally ambivalent we
feel solidarity with oppressed peoples
and sympathy with their nationalist
aspirations on the one hand but are also
in different circumstances repulsed by
what seemed to be the crimes perpetrated
in the name of nationalism notably
ethnic cleansing so it's not something
where typically most of us will say we
think nationalism
is in and of itself a good thing or a
bad thing sometimes it seems like a good
thing and sometimes it seems like a bad
thing and it would be interesting for
each of us to explore in our hearts when
we think one or the other
similarly nationalism creates dilemmas
for international justice do we
privilege the existing sovereign states
even in the face of nationalist
movements that are contesting the
legitimacy of those states or take a
more which in the States themselves of
course make a nationalist claim to their
privacy and their sovereignty or do we
take what might be a more cosmopolitan
view limiting sovereignty on behalf of
what are usually on sovereign
unrecognised aspiring news so that's the
responsibility to protect to which we
will be returning later in the semester
but much of these kinds of questions
about the responsibility to protect or
the pros and cons of supporting
nationalist movements and so forth are
really a reflection of the fact that
this is a very vexed area not only in
terms of definitions and policies but
also in terms of normative status of
nations and questions if we assume that
all nations deserve States then we're
fairly tolerant of the use of force as a
legitimate means for winning sovereignty
but if we don't assume that then we are
fairly tolerant of quite repressive
actions against aspirant nations and if
we're nationalists on our own behalf are
we what of other nationalisms if your
nation is your nationalism particular
istic in other words all you really care
that is your own nation your only and X
or do you think that everybody should
have a nation
nationalism so you're a sort of
universalistic if you will
nationalist so it's not only fine for
you to be a nationalist but everybody
should in which case you obviously in
one case you have no sympathy for any of
the people on the other outside of your
own community in the second case you may
acknowledge them but the chances are
that you're going to be competing over
some of the limited resources in the
world so they are certain a whole set of
normative questions which I commend to
you and there's some policy questions if
we think in terms of the competing
definitions and the competing
relationships among these kinds of
communities we need to be thinking about
what causes or what kinds of things
contribute to ethnic conflict because
one could imagine although it's a
stretch of world of Nations that all our
content there all have as much
sovereignty as they want they'd all have
have as much of the other goods that
they and values in the world that they
want that everybody who imagines him or
herself as a member of one of these
communities is actually in it and has no
obligations to any other communities one
could imagine that but of course in
practice there are communities that
aspire to values to make claims that are
at the expense of other communities so
there is ethnic conflict there is
competing nationalisms and competing
over territory competing over moral
claims competing over United Nations
recognition competing over all sorts of
things one of the ways to think about
this is to think about it in terms of
Nations as analogous to States and
international relations theory and
that's what very PO
does in his discussion of the security
dilemmas that contribute to ethnic
conflict that groups tend to see
themselves as threatened they tend to
try and protect themselves in doing so
they tend to seem threatening to other
groups and then you see the escalation
of that kind of security dilemma and
competition and it's hard from that
perspective to see how you can diminish
the mutual sense of threat that nations
that are contending with each other seem
to present to each other now again not
by contrast has a different view of the
origins of competition and violence but
that are so widespread among nations he
says it's not of course about ancient
hatreds nor by about external security
concerns whether these are manufactured
or provoked but by the dynamics of
in-group conflict so posey looks at the
relationships among the nations as an IR
theorist or the realist theorists would
and gang all by contrast says let's look
at how the groups operate within and see
how that affects their interaction with
other groups and he argues in a sense
back to the view of Nations and
nationalisms as the manufacture of
elites that elites provoke often provoke
conflict in order to solidify their
position within the community in
question and the power holders in
national groups and ethnic groups will
often be playing if you will a Janus
face game trying to solidify their
position within the group by behaving as
if there's a great threat outside the
group and
using the Solidarity within the group to
threaten the outside so from his vantage
point it's not simply how they interact
with each other but you also have to
look inside the group itself the major
conflict says he taking place along
ethnic lines throughout the world have
had their main causes not in ancient
hatreds again but rather the purposeful
actions of political actors who actively
create the violent conflict selectively
drawing in history in order to portray
it as historically inevitable read back
from that statement Lynch's discussion
of al-qaeda and bin Laden and you see
essentially nationalist Punk markets and
democracy has been a principal
aggravating cause of group hatred and
ethnic violence how is this so because
she argues markets and democracy benefit
different ethnic groups in such
societies therefore creating highly
unstable and combustible conditions
those words are hers so when you think
about markets in democracy you tend we
tend to think about them as having
impacts on things like citizens and
consumers or maybe producers but we
don't think about which are those formal
abstract content less identities in
which we are all interchangeable but in
practice of course markets democracies
political processes economic processes
and so forth do not treat us simply as
those faceless actors but differentiate
among us in part on the basis of
educational levels or ethnic ties or
wealth or all sorts of other kinds of
things that can contribute to these sort
of distinctions within society and
particularly where visit where certain
time
of professions or certain kinds of
economic endeavors were associated
historically with certain kinds of
ethnic groups these sorts of changes may
exacerbate may create an exacerbate
tensions within societies between those
very groups so as she puts it quite
simply but one could look around not
only at the cases she provides but in
other instances as well markets will
often not necessarily but will often in
practice concentrate wealth in the hands
of minorities competition for votes in
democracy if we're advocating
democratization often fosters demagogues
demagogues who will use their position
to stir up as as identity entrepreneurs
nationalists enthusiasms and these both
weather the impact in the market under
the impact of democratic politics will
create circumstances for a backlash
against markets or against democracy or
against the minority so that there are a
lot of things that can be understood as
perspectives on what contributes to
ethnic conflict it can be a security
dilemma it can be ethnic entrepreneurs
within a community it can be global
forces which shape will it reshape
relations among communities and
societies in particular States but it's
fairly clear whatever perspective you
bring to these sorts of questions we
have ethnic conflict and so the final
question and to which much of the
reading of this week is devoted is how
ethnic conflict NBD managed and ideally
resolved are there institutional
arrangements are there policies that we
can advocate that mitigate the conflict
that provide alternative nonviolent ways
of managing what are at this point for
better for worse now constructed
identities ideologies and
Nation ships so that's much of what you
will be thinking about between now and
your discussions there are power sharing
models there are advocates for partition
in particular cases or for secession say
it is impossible for these communities
to live together give them their own
independent states it is possible for
these communities to live together but
only if they are represented in
government as communities not simply in
as is a whole society of individuals so
advocates of minority rights advocates
of power sharing and so forth say it is
important to have community
representation not simply popular
representation and democracies those are
kinds of elements of power sharing and
by and large as you'll see the advocates
of power sharing of whom errant light
part is probably the most prominent
themselves concede that it doesn't
always work and it only probably works
well in very particular circumstances
there should be as he puts it
representatives of all the significant
groups in the government the group
should have autonomy the government
posts should be distributed
proportionally the minorities should
have vetoes on vital issues it's not
clear how realistic those does in errata
and are in most of the cases where we
are considering trying to manage ethnic
and national conflict partition has all
of the kinds of pros and concepts you
can imagine and Calvin and Kumar discuss
it in
but the last question is really whether
nationalism and national identities and
multiple natural isms in a particular
political unit or state can be
reconciled with democracy and the
democracy promotion discussion is vast
and important and we will be we've
talked about it a little bit already the
kinds of things that Robert Dahl talked
about when we looked at the origins of
liberalism and democracy we'll be
looking at democracy yet again later in
the semester but it's worth thinking
about the extent to which much of the
way we think about democracy is
confounded when people have not simply
individual identities as citizens and
popular representation is not simply the
representation of my interests and my
perspectives as an individual but also
has to take into account the aspirations
of people as members of communities and
particularly members of ethnic and
national communities and under those
circumstances democracy is not
necessarily ideally equipped to
represent those interests in ways that
satisfy the citizens so it may be and we
return to Dahl that part of what we need
to be thinking about when we think about
how to promote democracy particularly in
divided societies is to think about the
sequence of institutional innovation and
it may be that simply giving people the
universal suffrage and the vote lays the
ground more for the
the demagogues that I was talking about
before then it does resolves the kinds
of conflicts that are what the democracy
is supposed to address these this is the
debate which professor Snyder has been
not only social scientists in but an
advocate as providing a variety of kinds
of policy advice to the democracy
promotion community and I commend those
sorts of debates you for your sections
and I think that's probably enough I
have 10 15 minutes for questions